Finally, it's been a cold and snowy winter Ross.
Yeah, burr.
I know, but a young boy in Rhode Island
decided to go outside.
And no he wasn't building a snowman.
Ten-year-old Christian Stone was
at the hospital clearing snow
off the cars of essential workers.
And Christian's mom, Amanda and a family friend,
Abby were also out there helping Christian.
And they're all joining us now.
So please welcome Christian, Amanda and Abby!
(audience cheering)
Christian, this was all your idea
and I just want to ask what gave you the idea?
what made you want to go and help the frontline workers?
Well, the, everyone that works
at the hospital has to deal with COVID all day
and like all the other diseases and stuff
and they probably just want to get home from work.
So we though we would make it a step easier
for them by just, you know, fixing up like just doing this
so they don't have to do it.
The fact that you know, that obviously Amanda, as his mom
I think that you're really doing things right.
And you might be so proud.
Thank you.
I mean, do you have any advice for other parents like me?
I'm definitely very proud,
I just have always tried to raise him to be kind to others
and to just realize that maybe something as small
as wiping off cars can actually make somebody's day.
You don't really know what struggles
other people are going through.
So the smallest thing can have the biggest impact.
I love that, the smallest thing can, and for so
many people who don't know what they can do to help,
a little thing, like this can go such a long way.
I'm wondering when you were out there clearing the windows,
did you see any of the doctors or nurses looking out,
Like what, what are you doing?
Yeah, Abby, you were there, what did you see?
Yes um, so while we were cleaning the cars
Christian came up with a game.
Anytime we saw the headlights go on,
we would try and rush over to that car before they came out.
Cause they're warming up their car.
So we would go and start their car.
They would come out and that's when we went up to them.
Christian told him what we were doing.
And I had said that, you know,
your storms inside, our storms out here,
we'll handle it from here and get in your car and get warm.
And we'll take care of it from here.
Your storm's inside.
Come on!
(audience laughs)
Such an inspiration.
And we want to send you guys like on a family vacation.
Is that okay?
Yeah, best friends, yeah.
Okay, great.
Perfect, all right.
You're going to go on a five nights, six days Stay
at the Lego land resort in Florida,
because I just feel like you deserve
to go have some fun.
Lego Land!
That's right, you're going to stay there
at the new Lego Land Iron Island hotel
with the all-inclusive package,
including meals, from check-in through check out.
Daily admission passes to the theme park and water park too!
(audience clapping)
What the hell!
Yes!
That's for you!
Thank you so much!
No, thank you.
Thank You.
(upbeat cheerful music)